well now that my reviews of the Matrix
trilogy are done leading up to John wick
chapter 2 I just felt my OCD burning
inside of me and I had to be the
completionist that I am and talk about
the Animatrix which is an anthology film
of nine animated short films inspired by
the matrix universe some of them are
written by the Wachowskis themselves and
they're directed by some of the best
directors who are working in the anime
field at the time of this release and
I'm going to talk about all nine short
films in detail so if you've never seen
the Animatrix this review is going to
contain some spoilers the first one was
called final flight of the Osiris and it
directly relates to the Matrix Reloaded
this was actually shown in theaters
strangely enough before the film
dreamcatcher it was probably better than
watching dreamcatcher so there's that
the thing I dislike the most about this
short is its opening sequence which is
pure over sexualized fanservice for no
reason out of all the shorts on the
Animatrix I would say this one feels the
most like the film's it has a direct
correlation to it this is the ship that
discovered the machines were drilling to
Zion which in the Matrix Reloaded was
referenced by Niobe here these
geothermal ass transmission of the
Osiris the machines are digging in 2003
this animation was considered
spectacular movies like Final Fantasy
the Spirits Within had recently happened
and a lot of people compared the
animation style in the final flight of
the Osiris to that film it's fine for
what it is the opening sword fights
completely unnecessary some of the
action and it is okay it has a few cool
action II moments but for the most part
this short just feels like needless
filler something The Matrix Reloaded
would definitely have a lot of the next
short was called the second Renaissance
Part 1 and this was directed by the lead
director of blue submarine number 6
which is an anime that I really enjoyed
and this one is good like disturbingly
good this one explores mankind's
beginning with AI how we as a people
develop robots in our own image and how
they eventually rose up against us this
one is permeated with disturbing imagery
as we witness mankind's revolt against
machines when one machine rises up
against his master and kills him this
leads all humanity to
instantly hate all machines and what's
so effective about this short in
particular is that it shows the
political repercussions of what a battle
between humanity and sentient AI would
be like it gives us a look into the eyes
of what a human might want to do if a
robot revolted this short actually puts
us in the mindset of the machines
it shows some machines being destroyed
by humans and they don't feel the same
way as some of the other robots that
have risen up against humanity so it's
rather disturbing to witness and this is
continued even more effectively in the
second Renaissance part two where we see
mankind try to bomb the Machine City
because all the robots go to one
specific place to try to thrive there
and create their own peaceful Society
since they're no longer welcomed in
humanity and after mankind's attack
fails on the robots they then turned to
the Sun robots last remaining energy
source of solar energy and they scorch
the sky which is referenced in the first
matrix film but we know that it was us
that scorched the sky and then we get a
surprisingly effective documentation of
what it might be like if mankind went to
war with sentient AI and some of the
imagery here is unrelentingly disturbing
and it genuinely got under my skin this
is one of the best in the Animatrix it
shows mankind as an unrelentless ly
bloodthirsty race that will wipe out
anything that's oppressing it and it got
me the next short is called kid story
written by the Wachowskis and directed
by shin achiara watanabe my favorite
anime director of all time the man
behind terror in resonance kids on the
slope samurai champloo and of course
Cowboy Bebop
and this short tells the story of how
that really annoying kid in the Matrix
Reloaded who was obsessed with neo
gottfrid from The Matrix the animation
style here is something that is very
unique it has a hard-edged
almost messy imperfect quality to it
that really breathe some life into this
short and makes it feel like you're
watching something almost unplanned we
get to watch as this kid goes on the
dark side of the net and tries to
communicate with people he feels like
he's always in a dream state and this is
when we get his first connection with
neo who then later contacts him while
he's in school and there's this really
great chase seen throughout the school
and this one presents this kid as the
first person who ever willingly exited
The Matrix on his own with no one's help
he actually wakes up in the real world
because his desire to do so was so
strong this isn't really explored in the
film's save for the fact that neo keeps
telling the kid
hey I didn't save you you did it for
yourself I told you kid you found me I
didn't find you I know but you got me
out you saved me save yourself so you
kind of just have to accept it because I
guess the Wachowski x' wrote it and hey
it's a short film it happened it's well
directed I love the animation style the
next short is called program and this
was directed by the man behind vampire
hunter D bloodlust and Ninja Scroll and
if you've ever seen any of his films
which are highly stylized highly violent
and filled with a ton of boobs you will
instantly recognize these character
designs they look exactly like all of
his films and one of my favorite things
about this short is the animation it's
breathtaking it's so beautiful there's
very exciting action sequences in this
short I love the character designs but
at its core this short doesn't have
anything going on it's eventually
revealed to be this big test and it was
really just in the characters minds and
it doesn't really add anything to this
story it's basically just a cool-looking
short with some really great action
sequences some standout animation and
that's about it there isn't really much
else under the surface of programs so
there's not really much else to say
about this short the next one is called
world record and it's directed by the
man behind redline if you ever seen
redline you'll instantly recognize that
this animation is very similar to
redline this is the one that feels the
least like a matrix inspired shorts we
have an athletic track runner who really
wants to break a world record and
essentially he runs so fast during one
of his meets that he actually wakes up
briefly in the real world and a machine
has to put him back to sleep because his
desire in the matrix to go faster and to
do more in his body than anyone else
could actually caused him to wake up in
that red
pod beyond that this short doesn't
explore much else it's probably my least
favorite short in the Animatrix the
animation is unique but I'm not really a
fan of this style it's the kind of
animation style that you notice more
than you let fade into the background
which for me is a flaw when you're
constantly aware of how strange
everything is animated it's unique and
different and I applaud them for that
but in the long run there really isn't
much happening in this short and unlike
program I don't really like the
animation style on this one and since
there's nothing really under the surface
this is probably my least favorite short
in the entire film the next short is
called Beyond and this comes from one of
the directors of two other anime
anthology films memories and robot
carnival this guy provided shorts for
these films as well I love the animation
style here it's very vibrant colorful
lifelike things move with a lot of
energy there's a lot of frames that are
put into this animation so it feels very
fluid this one tells a story of a girl
who's looking for her cat and eventually
stumbles on what the kids are calling a
haunted house it's a place where they
seem to be able to defy gravity where
really weird shapes and sounds appear
where things that just don't make sense
happen and everyone in the neighborhood
just thinks this area is haunted we as
viewers know this is a glitch in the
matrix I love the idea of all paranormal
phenomena just being attributed to a
glitch in the matrix when we see UFOs
when we see vampires when we think we
saw an alien or a ghost it was probably
just a glitch in the matrix and I love
the fact that they have little ways of
explaining all of these things within
the matrix universe and this short
explored that and although nothing
really happens beyond exploring that I
like the way this short is directed as I
said I like the way the animation style
looks and I just like the idea of
paranormal phenomena actually being able
to be attributed to something in the
matrix universe the next short is called
a detective story and once again
gratefully was directed by Shinichiro
Watanabe he got to make two shorts in
this film and this is easily my favorite
one this short is brimming with energy I
felt like I could smell the shots it's
so well captured
you can really tell Shinichiro Watanabe
love of film noir in this short as we
watch a detective who gets sent on a
mission to try to locate Trinity you get
a lot of classic film noir style jazz
music while a detective narrates in a
very raspy voice he eventually comes to
find Trinity and he realizes that it was
actually agents using him to get to
Trinity and I loved the way all of this
comes together on this train
it is a short there's not much to it you
can't really say there is much to any of
these shorts because they're very brief
short films that analyze little things
in the matrix and give us different
ideas about things that could happen
maybe in the Matrix universe what I love
about this short is the style the voice
work and the action sequence on the
train it's so well animated and it looks
so different I adore it it's easily my
favorite short in the entire film to be
honest I like to see this short as a
feature movie the last short is called
matriculated and it was directed by
Peter Chung the man behind MTV's Aeon
Flux and if you've ever seen Aeon Flux
you can instantly tell by the animation
style of this short the same people were
behind it these are people who have
created their own little digital version
of the matrix it's just a little world
that's not the actual matrix but they
can insert themselves into it and they
are trying to capture machines insert
them into this world and then teach the
machine the best parts of humanity
things like empathy and love and caring
and how one can sacrifice himself for
someone else and they actually do that
they capture a machine insert this
machine into the matrix and then use a
series of bizarre dream like psychedelic
imagery to try to convince this machine
to be more like a human and to actually
care for humanity and it works these
characters are then attacked by
sentinels and this one robot actually
tries to defend them and it ends on a
very very creepy shot of this robot
alone staring at all of these dead
bodies from afar
looking at this compound thinking what
is he thinking
it's very thought-provoking this is a
short that at first I was like I hate
this this is my least favorite one but
as soon as I realized what they were
doing and I looked more into the imagery
of it I began to appreciate it a lot
more oh
all the Animatrix is a movie that
basically explores different facets of
the Matrix universe gives us very
stylized depictions of what could happen
it's able to take small details the
film's never explored and then go into
them like what about haunted phenomena
well that's just the glitch in the
matrix
what if someone pushed themselves so
hard physically could they actually wake
up in the real world on their own could
someone decide they wanted to wake up in
the real world and just be left from the
matrix could that happen
what about random people who just exist
like a detective or something what is he
doing with his day in this digital world
I really like the fact that it was able
to explore these small little facets of
the matrix universe and do it in a fun
and mostly compelling way my biggest
flaw with the N matrix as a whole is
that the majority of the stories just
don't have much weight or impact or
emotion underneath them they're just
really cool short films and that's what
most short films are like most short
films are just like hey here's my style
this is what I'm going for
here's a fun little idea and here's my
way of saying it so when you bunch nine
of them together into one package you're
inevitably going to get a somewhat empty
experience but for the most part
especially as an anime fan this is a
compelling movie and I'm going to give
the Animatrix of B well guys I have
completed my matrix reviews I am so glad
I was able to do that please do check
out my reviews of the Matrix Reloaded
and the Matrix Revolutions which I've
just posted recently and both of them if
you missed those reviews I did include
an old childhood short film inspired by
the matrix you guys are the best thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes